la llegada de la vacuna a colombia no
solamente fue tardía sino además en muy
escasas cantidades pues por supuesto
esto es resultado de la negociación que
se inició muy tarde en relación con
otros países de américa
son uno de los últimos países en iniciar
la vacunación ya esto hay que añadirle
que el inicio de la misma que fue el día
de ayer se inició apenas con 18 dosis
aplicadas y con un gran espectáculo de
tipo publicitario y político más parecía
una promoción política una promoción
comercial que el comienzo de un programa
de salud pública para el país los
médicos no estamos acostumbrados a esto
es así que el tratamiento a los
pacientes debe tener no solamente
consideración sino que la prudencia en
la exposición de los pacientes cuando se
le está realizando un procedimiento